الان الى اجواء المونديال المنتخب المغربي
ورغم عدم تمكنه من بلوغ اعتب نهائي اغلى
المسابقات الكرويه تلقى ارشاده كبيره من
وسائل اعلام عالميه وصفات صحيفه لكيب
الفرنسيه المنتخب المغربي بالشجاعه بعد
المباراه المصيريه مشيره الى ان اسود
الاطلس لم يمنح الفرصه للاعبي المنتخب
الفرنسي بالظهور بمستواهم المعتاد صحيفه
ديليماني البريطانيه كتبت ان المنتخب
المغربي كان الطرف الافضل والاقوى في معظم
فترات اللقاء غير ان نقول ما التتويز بكاس
العالم في المقابل الصحيفه
الايطاليه قالت ان المنتخب الفرنسي في
النهائي لكن التصفيقه والتحيات يذهبان
للمغرب ويتطرقت صحيفه ماركا الاسبانيه
للحديث عن وليد الركراكي الذي دخل تاريخ
المجال بعد ما قاد طريقه ليصبح اول منتخب
عربي وافريقيا يظهر في الدور قبل النهائي
لكاس العالم
[تصفيق]